Hello Freak bitches.
What about the idea is that the universe is in a constant state of contraction
and expansion?
No,
it's up.
Been abandoned.
Some physicists to argue that it's,
there's a cycle because it looks nice and they are.
I think most of most people,
I mean there's some people who were arguing for that,
trying to take pictures.
Well,
I think they're trying to type their ignorance and something that isn't any more
plausible in the picture that it expands forever and as far as we can tell,
the most likely possibilities that are universal expand forever fought to make
you a little bit happier.
It's quite possible.
The best pictures that we have of our,
of,
of the early universe is that we actually,
our universe isn't unique,
isn't alone.
That there are many universes,
we call it a multiverse and that at any instant in time and kind of a cosmic
super time,
there's always university being born so that that multi-verse might be,
might be infinite and eternal.
Where are they outside of our universe?
How's that even possible?
Of course,
it's possible.
I understand.
Okay.
Well,
first of all,
the simplest possibility is that they're outside the region.
We can see right for,
for,
for example,
the edge is our visible universe.
Space is expanding faster away from us than light because you know,
we taught you in school,
nothing can travel faster than light.
And you may remember that from scratch.
We lied.
Okay,
well no,
you have to parse it more carefully.
Like a lawyer.
Nothing can travel through space faster than light,
but space can do whatever the hell it wants.
So locally,
as I told you though,
radio host is,
is at rest they're not moving.
And and the other end of the galaxy at the other end of the visible universe and
we're rest,
but the space between us is expanding.
So that galaxy,
like a surfer is being carried away from us faster than light relative to the
water.
The surfer is moving,
right?
But relative to the shore,
the surfer is right,
right.
Okay.
So this,
this galaxy is not moving relative to its local surroundings,
but it's moving away from us faster than light.
And like a surfer in an undertow,
they can swim really fast in the water,
but if the water's moving away from the shore,
they'll never make it back to the shore.
Right.
And so that galaxy,
the light from that galaxy is traveling through space at the speed of light.
But it's the space in between us and the galaxies moving faster than light.
Then the poor light can ever make it to us.
We call that a horizon.
Wow.
So the space is traveling too far for the light to reach us so fast.
The triple spaces too fast.
So this light can't catch up with the expansion of space and it never gets to
us.
And that that galaxy disappears from our causal horizon.
We call it will never be able to see it.
We'll never be able to interact with it will never be okay.
And it could be that,
that there are different regions so far away from us.
We're space is expanding faster than light,
which,
which have a very different history than our own.
So there could be space,
could be infinite,
just our simple unit space that we know of and love could be infinite in extent
and different regions of that space had different histories and some of those
regions,
everything we can see,
we know emerged from a single point.
Okay.
We can tell that.
We can tell that by measuring the big bang expansion of everything we see and
working backwards and the university,
our visible universe was once smaller and smaller and smaller.
If you go back in time,
we can actually follow the laws of physics back to the earliest moments of the
big bang until those laws break down and we can make predictions about the
university would look like.
All those predictions agree exactly what the observations we make,
which tells us that that picture works.
But another region,
if you wish,
could have come from a different big bang,
but is that another universe or is it a part of the university?
Here's how we've changed and this is semantics,
but nontrivial semantics,
namely when I was a kid,
universe meant every everything,
right?
But we say that's it's pretty stupid definition.
A better definition is an operational one.
Universe means that region of space with which at one time we could have
communicated or one time in the future,
even if the future is infinite,
we might communicate with,
because that describes the region of space where cause and effect works some
measurable distance.
Yes.
And so that are we think of a universe is that region which could throughout
which everything could affect everything else ultimately in an infinitely long
time.
And in that picture,
universes can be restricted in size.
And then other regions which could never have affected us and which will never
affect us in the future.
We call other universes.
Uh,
and when,
and,
and now there are many different versions of a multiverse,
but that's the simplest version.
And this picture we call inflation,
which,
uh,
you know,
I talk,
I just did two little clips associated with the new book,
one force for a publisher and one was for big.
Think one is,
uh,
the universe and under two minutes.
So you can look up online,
look for Lawrence Krauss,
explains the universe in under two minutes where I talk about this cosmic
expansion and how it might mean there's a multiverse.
But the other is,
um,
I explained the universe in terms of this beer bottle that I talked about to you
earlier.
So you can,
that's a video,
you can watch that.
But it,
this theory of inflation,
which actually says are universal.
The,
the qualities that we see of our universe can best be explained if some early
time in the history of the universe when it was a billionth of a billionth of a
billionth of a billionth of a second old.
It had a huge expansion suddenly and increased in size by 30 orders of magnitude
in size,
in a billionth of a billionth of a billionth of a billionth of a second.
Which is by the way,
particle physics suggests is highly plausible even though,
okay.
And then,
and then,
and then it would produce a university.
It looks more or less like we look like you look like and and uh,
and it,
and it's right now the only explanation of what of how that would cause the
universe to look like,
what it looks like.
But the neat thing about inflation is it's eternal.
So inflation that puffing up and in our universe and then boom,
a hot,
big bang followed it.
Okay.
So the region,
universe,
universe puffed up by huge amount than all of that energy which was stored in
empty space,
got released like in the beer bottle and we got a hot,
Big Bang and the rest is history,
but that's locally but somewhere else at between us and their space is still
expanding exponentially and faster and faster and faster and only maybe
somewhere else today.
Boom.
Like an ice crystal forming boom,
that that region of space is suddenly left inflation and maybe a guilt a
gazillion years in the future,
they'll be another region of space that's expanding away from a summit much
faster than light.
So we'll never know about it.
We're suddenly that region,
these inflation and boom,
another hot big bang happens.
And it turns out in each of those hot,
big bangs,
after the inflation ends,
depending upon how it ends,
the laws of physics could be different in that universe and that,
so we tend to think it's quite likely that there are many,
many separate regions of space.
And in fact,
it's eternal.
So such regions or are forming eternally for all time and,
and,
and there are hot,
big bangs happening in many regions and the properties of each of those regions,
whether they're conducive to forming galaxies and stars and planets and people
may be different.
So we could say logically in that picture,
that the reason the universe looks like the way it does is because we're here to
measure it.
Oh my God,
we should leave it at that.
Okay.
We should close with that.
That is the mind blower of glassblowers.
Yeah.
Good.